Russ you and James have both been your  team's primary playmakers for the past  seven years how do you make the balance  work one guy off the ball the other on  in interchangeable or play it out as it  goes man James been friends for many  many years since I was 10 actually huh  well yeah we play with each other for  many years in Oklahoma City and so to be  able to win something you got a better  sacrifice some parts of your game and we  both understand that we both understand  that we have one common goal and that's  to win a championship so we understand  what we have to do on this I'm not  worried but I know James is not worried  about it  I can play off the ball I don't have to  touch the ball to impact the game and  that's the best way for me to get a  comeback and impact this team as I I can  do other things on the floor to be able  to make sure we have a better chance to  win it so